BTS are global pop superstars.
They've contributed billions of dollars to their country's economy...
...and are more than most to generate interest in South Korean culture.
They've even got involved in issues outside the pop world.
Perhaps the world's biggest band has spoken at the United Nations...
...and that President Biden at the White House.
But in South Korea, all able-bodied men have to undergo military service...
...before the age of 30.
They have to join up for between 18 and 21 months.
There's been a national debate about...
...whether BTS should be given an exemption...
...because of the huge service they've already given to South Korea.
The issue has even been discussed in the National Assembly.
The seven band members have now ended the speculation about their futures.
In a statement, they said they would serve in the military...
...out of respect, they said, for their country's needs.
That means resisting North Korea.
Among the glamour and glitter of the music business,...
...it's easy to forget that Seoul is under constant threat...
...from its belligerent neighbor to the north.
So for a few years,...
...BTS will say goodbye to the red carpet and screaming fans.
They'll exchange formal wear for army fatigues,...
...but they'll be back in three years when their time in the military is done.
Michael Bristow, BBC News.